j'accueille maintenant frédéric
beigbeder
attentive à vue mais non catherine il a
bu trop de votre cas mais alors qu'est
ce qu'on va faire catherine un compte
rendu
on va faire une consultation à la il
s'est arraché dans les loges torche et
il a bu trop de votre katana que j'avais
dit pas boire il peut l'aider on peut
vraiment catherine il veut vraiment pas
venir
ses parts dans la loge des praticables
non c'est pas une blague dénoncée canon
il est couché par tient à l'âge
catherine enfer belvédère et catherine
est bourré grand catry catherine labouré
du tout il ne peut pas venir c'est sûr
chercher elle me dit quand on vomit on
peut pas parler l'exercice maintenant
j'espère que vivien il vient samedi
prochain quand même ont failli finir je
sais que je vais le décor n'est pas très
beau mais à ce point là quand même bon
bah écoute voilà non je souhaitais qu'il
n'était pas bien quand on était encore
dans la batterie la tour et j'ai eu un
sentiment qui a trouvé torche et je les
trouvais un petit peu particulier bien
bon bon bah écoutes je vais libérer liu
d'abord qui doit allaiter ses six
enfants liés au pays par tous à la fois
mais au moins au moins
enfin vivre
sur 100
salut d'eau
c'est la première fois que ça m'arrive
j'ai vu j'ai vu des gens ne pas venir à
l'émission mais des gens venus respirer
l'horloge est incapable de rentrer sur
le plateau il servira que le type est
assez spontané comme n'est pas il est
parvenu est encore retenu bien ben
écoute frédéric ramé toi j'espère que ça
va mieux
amélie occupe toi de lui et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous il m'était impossible